so you've known Boris Johnson since he
was a boy together at Eton and then
Oxford University yes
how surprised are you that he has become
the UK prime minister I won't talk of
Prime Minister do you think he's gonna
be well I'm not really surprised I think
we could see that he's an ambitious
person he has a track record of doing
what people might feel hard or
impossible becoming mayor in London some
will say getting away with some things
he's he's done in politics clearly has
he's a popular person and he has always
been as a boy he was a very popular boy
at school and also at university he's
intelligent
so everybody who like I guess we who
knows him or we knew him knows that this
is something that he's always wanted to
do and although his path to the
Premiership might be a bit long-winded
in a way and it's not his first attempt
I guess but no we're not surprised I
think what's more difficult for him will
be the next few months dealing with
brexit in a very limited period of time
and it is Sir under certain present
circumstances and that I think will be a
huge challenge for him yes he told me so
he said he said that was already he was
already 10 years behind me that he was
going to go for it that's his words that
steely ambition sometimes it's quite
hard to work out who Boris Johnson is
sometimes we see this gesture sometimes
this pragmatist from being at school
with him who is he
because he came to school as Alexander
well I think he's somebody who who
learns fast who can adapt himself if
necessary knows what he wants to do an
intelligent person so in a way I think
that has served him
in his in his career so you see that
there may be some inconsistencies
viewing from the outside but it's I
think it's his way of adapting to the
circumstances and getting to where he
wants to be and when he did you see a
change in his character there to see him
develop into the Boris that we see now
well you know he was a he was a king
scholar but you know the way most boys
view scholars would you know the sort of
nerdy type the kind of thing but he
didn't fit into that picture at all he
was you know just his hair his way his
manner of speaking his humor he was a
very popular person so that's a sort of
Boris that that that the impression of
Boris that we all had and every time I
seen the news
you just kelp can't help thinking that
this is the Boris you you've always
remembered him
so the Boris Johnson that you see on the
news you believe because some people
have said you know he's possibly a
caricature is he really this gesture is
that an act or do you think he does put
on an act but that's him
so can we can we kind of public trust
what they see in here also previous
colleagues have accused him of being
fast and loose with the facts how's that
well that nuts up to this standard of
accountability that the public will hold
him to so it's not really up to him it's
really up to what the British public
expect from him and can can hold him to
account so I noticed for instance that
during the leadership contest
he was often asked on private matters
he just flatly refuses to give answers
and actually said something to the
effect that if that's gonna cost him the
the leadership so be it he say that what
comes first will Boris Johnson cooked
the country first or is Boris always
putting Boris Johnson first
well if he's if he's there now
it depends what he wants to be
remembered as so I'm sure that he'd want
to be remembered as somebody who
overcomes the challenges of these very
difficult times for the country but if
he does not stick to that path if he
does something that serves his own
interest then again you know the system
has to hold into account but knowing him
do you believe that his primary focus is
himself and his own ambition well I'm
sure he'd want to be seen as a success
so he he would have to do his best what
characteristics do you think he has to
make a good prime minister or about
Prime Minister you've done the job
yourself
you were Prime Minister of Thailand what
how do you think he'll where will he be
strong where will he have trouble well
we obviously have very different styles
although we have we are good friends
what I think he has as a as a strong
point at present is the
unconventionality because we are I mean
really Britain is facing very uncertain
and uncharted territory
I think he can appeal to many many
people who may not share his ideology
and if you could use that to good effect
he could unite the country and try to
deal and solve this brexit problem is
such a huge
how Pan Boris Johnson succeed where
others arguably have fail what is it do
you think that he might be able to do
again I think because he has an appeal
that goes beyond people who share his
his muse and ideology so he could
somehow get those people to support and
get behind him in his efforts then maybe
you could pull it off it's gonna be very
difficult finally you were Prime
Minister he is a prime minister what tip
would you give him well you know work
hard be honest and do your best